hey folks it's precon review time I'm
going to be critiquing the Eternal might
precon for ather drift and offering some
potential points of improvement the last
two prons I've discussed have impressed
me with their construction seeming
surprisingly streamlined in their
functionality and easily upgradeable
into a quite decent magic deck it's
actually been a bit disappointing like
what am I supposed to say aside from
this is pretty good cut these five bad
cards and it'll be even better
thankfully that's not a problem with
this precon though containing good card
quality lots of nice assorted zombie
cards and some nice attention to detail
in terms of Aesthetics in terms of
construction this deck is a hot mess
Express a disgusting mishmash of
conflicting game plans and synergistic
dead ends and I'm excited to tackle it
to start with though let's talk about
what this deck is trying to accomplish
the commander of this deck is tet a five
Mana 44 in esper colors with vigilance
and Menace as well as the following text
whenever you attack draw a card then
discard a card whenever you draw a card
zombies you control get plus one plus
one until end of turn so on the surface
this is a card that rewards token
zombies or otherwise wide Boards of
zombies and also a card that rewards big
draw that happens before the combat
damage step in a turn simple effect but
there are a lot of implied features of
this card that we should keep in mind to
be maximally effective TT wants a large
Board of zombies to attack with as well
as a large draw spell to amp up the
buffet grants and it's also a thing that
is likely going to be a removal magnet
if we have a large board since it can
threaten a lot of damage importantly
this means that the deck will want a lot
of Mana both to pay the five Mana
casting cost and also either draw some
cards or hold up mana to protect it
looking at the rest of the deck some
parts of it reflect these specific needs
there are eight cards that create small
zombie tokens and three Army generators
cards that create or add counters to a
single growing zombie token and there
are also a handful of cards that create
four four zombie tokens as well the deck
also contains a healthy nine ramp spell
to help bolster it up to larger
quantities of Mana from there the deck
also has a large number of zombie
creatures in it which rign from cards
that drain opponents to Lords to draw
spells and Beyond an interesting
additional package in the deck is the
discard package the alternate Commander
for this deck is hashan scarabs fist
which can allow a player to make four
four zombie copies of discarded
creatures and the deck also contains a
handful of other discard payoffs the
amount of discard in the deck isn't
wildly large though consisting of five
or six cards that allow you to discard
plus a handful of cycling cards there's
also a light graveyard package to go
along with this rounding out the deck we
have a pretty average number of removal
spells overall this deck will be looking
to create a wideboard of zombies and
utilize its cute discard and graveyard
sub themes and swing in at opponents
with a tet buffed board I obviously
preempted My overall thoughts on this
deck a bit but I'll start with what I
like about what's happening here as I
said earlier it has a larger than
average ramp suite for an esper deck
which I think is appropriate for this
game plan crowded Crypt and bontu's
Monument both stand out as fun ramp
options with a lot of utility in this
deck offering token production and drain
respectively this deck also contains
some number of token producers and some
of these are pretty good I like the ones
that create one one white zombie tokens
and On Wings Of Gold's flying plus
Anthem effect is good enough to make the
card seem worthwhile even though this
isn't a deck with a super heavy
graveyard theme at least by a Zombie
Deck standards
the manabase here is excellent really
robust symbol counts even with a couple
of great colorless utility LS and a
moderately high but not overwhelming tap
land density that also gives players
room to gradually update tap lands with
better untapped duels there are also
some number of cards that slot in quite
elegantly to this deck forgotten
creation pairs perfectly with both tet
and Hason as do the newly printed profit
of the Scarab and rtom Mystic there are
also gestures at a number of packages
that could exist a couple impact Tremor
style cards paired with the de token
package and a selection of different
graveyard and discard enablers and
payoffs to give a sampling platter of
what that could look like that's the
most generous way to view this deck in
my mind it is a sample of possible game
plans Andor a toolbox of possible
implements for beginning the Journey of
building them so what about this as a
deck that's trying to play a game of
Magic the Gathering well it's a bit
disappointing hashan has gotten a lot of
attention as an undeniably cool
secondary Commander but it doesn't even
really work as a secondary Commander the
deck just doesn't have enough discard to
consistently enable hash aon's ability
with hashan in the 99 you at least have
the consistent discard effect of temit
but he's also a five Mana card with an
overrun esque ability so trusting him to
stick around as an engine is highly
optimistic this lack of discard likewise
stands out in the case of other discard
payoffs such as lzp chance and Arch
fiend of ifer though those at least get
triggered by the deck cycling lands the
deck's graveyard package is another
thing that stands out it's not massive
but it is decidedly present as you'd
expect with a zombiie deck this deck is
kind of thin on ways to enable it though
most zombie decks would be using
sacrifice abilities in addition to
discard and while this deck does have
the sorts of payoffs when creatures die
that those decks tend to have it's
almost entirely lacking in waste to
sacrific creatures the result is that
this dech really lacks a lot of what
might give a Zombie Deck a sense of
mechanical identity its disjointedness
causing both play pattern issues when
disperate Synergy packages don't line up
and Vibes issues when it plays just like
a generic blob of typo mid-range
gameplay instead of you know like a
Zombie Deck okay so I obviously have
issues with this deck's handling of some
traditional key zombie sub themes but
let's set that aside this is a precon
this is meant to be a toolbox Andor a
sampling platter we can give it some
slack does this deck at least hold up in
supporting tet as a commander are we
forging an alternative zombie play style
here in some ways the answer is yes but
in a lot of other ways the answer is no
as I said earlier this deck's ramp and
Mana are well constructed which is good
as tet is the sort of card that's going
to work better when the deck has Mana to
play him plus something else in a turn
the token generating Suite is okay and
actually contains some pretty high
quality stuff but there are fewer cards
that create small zombie tokens than I'd
like creating four4 zombie tokens is
cool and all but tet's design heavily
incentivizes pairing him with lots of
small zombies so the bigger tokens with
more rigorous requirements to be created
simply feel out of place even if they're
more aesthetically fitting even more
problematically this deck doesn't have
much of the sort of bursty draw that
pairs best with tet there isn't a lot of
draw overall and a lot of the draw that
is here isn't great for taking advantage
of T's ability there isn't a reliable
way to sacrif face corpse augur nor any
good way to let midnight Reaper or
Undead augur translate into temit
triggers and you're not going to tap
down your zombies to Crypt breaker if
you want to swing in that turn most of
the other draw options are Mana
expensive so you're looking at 10 Mana
minimum to do a tet plus draw maneuver
the one thing working in tet's favor
here is the half dozen or so cycling
cards in the deck but at that point
you're paying five Mana for the
commander plus two Mana to cycle during
the combat step for roughly an undead
Warchief worth of anthem
the final problem is this deck's
interaction Suite it has 10 cards to
perform a removal role in some way or
other which might work for a faster
Zombie Deck but I'm not sold on this
deck's ability to win quickly worse it
has very little protection and no
counter spells a blue deck that's
vulnerable to removal and board wipes
runs no counter spells come on I don't
know this deck isn't unplayably bad or
anything but it fails to meaningfully
commit to any of its sub themes and with
the way it's currently built its command
Zone feels AR at best just a generic
Zombie Guide that gives the deck its
colors it is a bit more cohesive when we
look at the visual presentation with a
clear emphasis on Amo cat style zombies
and there's certainly some admirable
effort put into new art for a lot of the
cards present I don't usually treat
preon reviews as product reviews or
value reviews you know I'm much more
interested in the deck and the sort of
experience that Wizards of the Coast is
handing to a newer player who is pulling
this out of a box to play a game of
Commander with but I'll make a minor
exception here as a product there's a
lot going for this and if you are a
zombie player who's looking for a bundle
of good zombie cards plus some cool new
Arts this might absolutely be a great
purchase just don't buy this if you're
looking for a cohesive deck out of the
box because this is not that with all
that said I still want to try an upgrade
for this when I first saw this pron my
immediate thought was that it' be cool
to morph it into a full hash Aon deck
but honestly this deck is so far from
enabling Hason well that I'm inclined to
stick with temit instead and see what we
can do with 15 swap outs to try and
actually let him feel like a legitimate
Commander so let's do that and I'm going
to start by talking about what we're
cutting binding mummy and Twisted
Abomination aren't great in general and
I'm also going to cut out a couple
discard payoffs that aren't adequately
supported here sorry hashan beyond that
Masid Nexus seems out of place here my
best guess is it's just here to give
more people access to maswood Nexus and
I'm going to also cut out a handful of
zombies that are just a bit mediocre
this is a rare gravecrawler L with no
sacrifice this card just doesn't really
do anything nothing Beyond these
particularly offends me but I will trim
a handful more mediocre cards just to
make space for better support these are
cards that are just on the weaker side
mechanically or which don't tie in
particularly well with the game plan I'm
trying to cultivate for our additions
the first order of business is that I
want to add a bunch more drawn filtering
since they do double duty in smoothing
out the way this deck plays and making
it punchier with tet keep watch distant
Melody pack of The Serpent and rafine
all allow the deck to give its zombies a
massive pump up for a reasonable amount
of Mana in addition to these I'm
choosing to add three cards for
protection that can also draw cards
which are change of plans you find the
villain's Lair and your temple is under
attack and these are nice because of
their flexibility the other thing I'm
choosing to add is cards that create
zombie tokens three total in this case
siphon flesh and dark salvation both
provide removal and token generation and
end ranks of the Dead is a good singular
zombie token maker honestly there are a
bunch of other zombie token generators
in the $ to $10 range that I didn't add
due to price and if you're really trying
to build a good tet deck you should
probably go find some of those Vina
stands out as a card that is absurdly
good in temit deck performing both key
tasks I'm looking for at a good rate for
a few final additions diaph Captain is
just a generically good zombie and I'm
basically having it replace a couple
zombie typle cards I'm cutting lethal is
a removal spell that also includes a
good amount of draw discard filtering
and it's easily payable with black
zombie tokens fwar Stone and Ponder are
here to give some extra ramp and
filtering respectively just smoothing
out the overall game plan the last
Edition is sehid Coliseum a land that
can provide a burst of draw triggers at
a great rate at a point in the game when
the deck is looking to close things out
through these changes my hope is that
tet will be more consistently useful
sticking around longer and providing
larger Buffs to zombies the addition of
more zombie tokens and removal will
hopefully also direct the game plan of
the deck in the right direction tet
definitely isn't my favorite Commander
like there's definitely less depth there
than with the alternate Commander hashan
but I still can't help but respect the
attempt at making a different sort of
Zombie Deck one more based around
drawing and discarding than around death
triggers and sacrificing hopefully we
see more exploration in this direction
in the future and hopefully future
zombie precons end up a bit more
coherently constructed did announcement
I have a PO Box now and the address is
on screen feel free to send me your
favorite card or a handwritten poem
proclaiming Your Love of brush Wags the
PO Box isn't wildly large so don't send
me anything bulky as there is a solid
chance it will be thrown away instead of
finding its way to me this should go
without saying but please also don't
send me anything dangerous or disgusting
thanks if I get enough cards I might
turn them into a deck or make them into
a video of some sort delicious future
content for the gaping content hungry Ms
of the world world with that said thanks
for watching and thanks to architect for
supporting the channel I'm a fan of
architect's UI a thing that was on
screen basically the whole video and an
especially nice feature for tweaking
decks is the maybe board categories
which let me keep thoughts and card
editions nice and organized a link to my
upgraded precon list is in the
description I also want to thank my
patrons for their support some of whose
names are on screen now I'll be doing a
Q&A next week so if you want to submit
questions for that and or watch it you
can sign up for $3 a month as the link
in the description all right bye now